this is my first cake I've ever made I'm
really proud of you it looks really good
like it looks really really good
hey guys guess what day today is you
don't have to guess because it's already
popping up on the screen it's May 6
which means it's Casey's birthday I
cannot believe a whole another year has
gone by my man's getting older just
kidding okay so he is downstairs right
now we're getting lunch ready it's
Casey's birthday and he's one of the
many people that get to have a
quarantine birthday we don't really get
to celebrate anywhere outside of the
house but yesterday I went to the
grocery store and I bought a box cake
like a cake in a box kind of thing the
plan is to bake him a cake yeah and I
also did my makeup cuz I was like I
gotta look pretty today or him this is
like a little treat cuz I never do my
makeup these days or actually get
dressed I am like wearing actual clothes
throughout this whole week there have
been like like his birthday presents
have come in the mail so for example we
have a vinyl machine player thing a
record player that's what it's called
so he's been wanting this one from Elton
John Lynyrd Skynyrd and Creedence
Clearwater and also I got him eckhart
totally a new earth this one is the
second book ^ now which is I mean Isaac
Casey Casey's been reading this book as
you can see he's he just started it and
also I ordered him three other books
that are my favorite books I'm like here
enjoy cuz he actually likes holding the
books and like reading the physical copy
but for me I like listening to
audiobooks while holding the physical
copy I have to have both I don't know
why I'm so weird but I need to hear it
in my ear as like I'm following the
actual books so anyway I've already
listened to these books
I know he's gonna love them so I gotten
those just that the other books have
been came in because I also got him the
subtle art of not giving a bleep and
what else I'm bleep yourself
like Gary Bishop all these books have
the f-word in it those are coming in and
then he was so sweet because he got me
the cure kiss me kiss me kiss me we're
trying to grow our vinyl collection he
also got me this mana Volume one so that
was really cool and I was trying to
think like what what should we do for
dinner I don't know why I didn't think
about this but yesterday whenever went
grocery shopping all I got was the K and
some beer cuz he want to eat because
yesterday was Cinco de Mayo so he really
wanted like a Mexican themed dinner so
we ordered some Mexican food I got him
some services and I just completely
forgot to consider tonight's dinner so I
was thinking maybe I can go to sugar
fish and get him some sushi cuz he's
been craving sushi for a long time and
yeah I don't know just trying my best to
make his birthday special cuz uh-huh
it's Quarantine birthday but luckily
Casey doesn't really care about his
birthday that much she's one of those
people that it's like don't get me
anything don't do anything my birthday's
not important you know when you love
someone you still want to make make
their birthday somewhat special so
that's kind of what's going on today
birthday boy thank you Benny's complain
yo chill more mija Mutulu miss pasa Mita
me Munda Spanish right back at you yeah
so how does it feel to be 32 I feel old
and not that the number makes me feel
old that this morning after we showered
and got ready we actually got ready for
once
yes we got dressed and like we showered
I did
make up and everything just got dressed
in my hair to the best of my ability to
give my hair so Jackie I got a picture
haven't fixed the bald spots and it's
getting along to the point where it's
really hard to him to style it in
general we found how many I plucked a 9
it plucks out 9 grey hairs from this his
head just beautiful a head here yeah I'm
turning to a silver fox yeah yeah what
become a silver fox stuff you do you
want to be there I believe him in next
time true it's like the cool way of
getting old you know it's like oh oh oh
you don't want to be old but then like
when you put a spin of it like like
silver fox like distinguished older
gentleman then I'm like not a bad idea
right have aged right into it you know
yeah exactly we should just let them
grow out next time true but yeah I still
have to fix this somehow honestly I'm
really scared
try to fix it cuz I don't want to make
it worse hey we don't fix it it's it's
long and it might as well be long and
just long because I was starting to itch
my ear like right yeah comes over and
like it's it she filled it along maybe I
can try um he'll fix it but makes me
wonder because I had long hair before
I'm like a good idea with long hair
before you know what we met your hair
was like really and I had like Bruce Lee
hair like a somewhere between Bruce Lee
hair and like Jesus here mm-hmm
no Jesus hair is like way like down here
oh you didn't know me then what girl
long enough where I was like borderline
Jesus here yeah like hell I wore Pina
all the time even in the summers cuz and
just how much hair just a beanie was the
only thing that felt right to keep it
all tidy
oh really
how long was this definitely at my
shoulders but like not in a way that
like the bangs didn't come down to her
shoulders it was just like kind of like
you had baby it was a moppy Jesus hair
so you were getting lunch ready even
though you're the birthday boy
while you were getting a lunch ready I
was getting the space ready so was it
worth it is it pretty
is it nice to look at this is the
dessert might might be spoiling explain
my appetite here I know to something
like I feel bad you haven't you haven't
seen a done up face in a while sure I
get I get sneak peaks here in America
then you're like I'm getting ready I'm
like okay and then like you'll come down
to get some water drinks or whatever
yeah beautiful mermaid go back upstairs
and lay like until next podcast shoot I
guess Oh No see like this time I put in
the work just for you true just so you
can enjoy and I got dressed - I'm
wearing I'm wearing a but number ones
that morning but not forever I know who
stick photos true Dakota the stick
photos
[Music]
Cheers happy birthday baby
thank you my wife bought me my favorite
beer wrench try not that I'm a beer
connoisseur or anything I just like red
stripes because of the bottle shortness
Dougie I do like the flavors not a bad
beers but I really got kind of got
spitting by the shape of the bottle I
was like oh what bottle what beer
companies do this in red stripe it's
gonna conduct that retro looking down
and I just like red stripe the
aesthetics of it is nice alright so for
lunch on my birthday I decided I wanted
to eat some bratwurst and some red
sprite because it takes me back to when
I first moved out on my own and one of
the first thing it's like we me and my
roommate's ever made and like constantly
made and like I don't know I just it was
like the thing that we would just eat
and then there was a barbecue we would
make this and there was a birthday was
made this and it was this combination of
foods feel bad because I didn't prepare
it for you because I just want to spoil
you on your birthday and do everything
for you you spoiled me with your looks
already so I'm going to stop right there
I don't think I can handle any more no
so then like I kind of feel like oh man
but I did fight for you you did but no
for dinner it's gonna be all on me okay
okay good it can you tell me
oh yeah did you talk to the camera by
the way this is how you eat posole okay
all right I hope we celebrate Cinco
DeMayo yesterday with some of this talk
about that how you want it how you
wanted Mexican food sounds like anything
for you birthday boy okay so this is
what I do and it's really weird and I
don't care and I love it because my aunt
taught me this when I was really young
and I've only been able to box little
bit this way so you hook it up with some
sour cream and then you kind of like mix
it up all up in there and you put spread
sour cream on top
Dada can get this all he's a sous chef
oh and you get slime oh really
he brought me the pepper you put some
lime in the pasola then some lime in the
loo
my mouth is watering and then some salt
Olympus is so unhealthy but there's the
only way you can eat it a lot of
I think I went a little overboard of the
sour cream but it's okay because I love
it that's the way you like it and then
you pour some on here just a little bit
like that and then no it's good it's my
birthday too
I don't think I've ever had it exactly
like that before no cuz you don't like
dare you know that don't like Gary it's
just that I am very sensitive with my
skin I do love Dario mm-hmm right I'm
shower cream there's a nice touch right
play on temperature too is sour creams
cold
yes it's crunchy from the thing it's
creamy look at the hot that is oh they
and then with the line so I growing up
my family would be like ah it looks like
mom it this is how a Michaels over frost
now watched Django and chain yesterday
oh yeah what are we making here we're
making your second favorite red velvet
because your first favorite it's like
chess but that's legit let's just say it
the ingredients to me because I really
wanted to make you a cake from scratch
uh-huh but but then I looked at the
ingredients and I when I went grocery
shopping yesterday there wasn't any
flour so
sorry I'm cool with take a mix gonna get
box okay you know what make sure you can
also just get my third favorite cake
what is that could it be your first
favorite cake which is carrot cake so we
would both win win it's a win-win I
think Eric is falling down yeah yeah
what's your number one now did it
something else take its place you know I
loved it as much as oh yeah so are like
top twos and threes are like all
together in like because this is our
wedding cake red velvet like kind of
like bumped it up so I think we have the
same order of favorite our captors are
all the same happy are and we're so
meant for each other
our takes if you have naked Nora said
playlists were the things that can bring
two people together for us and be the
cakes that we like yeah I like it a lot
you look good in this kitchen that's why
I say the things I say
yeah I think between your hair your
wardrobes the a-frame what you're doing
in the kitchen the backsplash of the
kitchen now cool our kitchen our houses
you look fantastic
oh my god you just brought these two
things out I just realized what you're
doing here you're making layers to this
thing yeah they're really baking a cake
oh my god you're gonna put frosting in
between the two layers and then you're
gonna coat the whole thing with frosting
this is the first real birthday cake
I've ever had like one that was homemade
and like made by someone that I love
well I mean we didn't have to see the
box
was there a box I don't that into it
[Music]
yeah yes
[Music]
oh and we had candles so that forgot to
buy them yesterday yep you can obviously
tell that I saved these for the last
time cuz I'm like what a waste so just
throw them away after one you true this
unsub bernsen's for you man you're so
old I don't think we have any candles
you're gonna one do I do 23 24 25 26 27
28 29 30 31 32 you're lucky boy nice we
have enough until you turn 35 you know
your oven you don't you should just have
one candle I guess you know you're old
when you when you should just use one
can okay there's just so much more work
to do oh yeah what number is that
usually what age do you turn when you go
it's okay do you don't need to put all
the candles out just put one candle it's
just for me to blow it out like what
what age that yeah did you have cake so
you have cake you didn't bring you like
a light bin but you know how they have
your information right when you go to
resort did get which I saved they did
give me an envelope say happy birthday
but there was nothing oh you gave me
like a little talk with all right okay
that's okay yeah this is the first year
I think of my entire life
I do blow out a candle on my birthday
crazy is it something you feel like you
missed out on or was it a good time
there's a lip it was a liberating moment
you're like oh birthdays are not as
important as I thought they were or
whatever I remember one year when I was
really really upset
cuz I was grounded on my birthday and I
was just like man all I wanted was just
a camp just like for some reason a
candle on my birthday was always really
important to me but this last year
obviously wasn't ii forgot and then you
grew up I know this does not work like
it's just funny how like you place
importance on things when you're younger
that are really not that important
true and then the older you get the more
you realize like that's so stupid it's
so nice that's true yeah I experienced
that with with with Isaac it's like
Isaac places a lot of emphasis and
importance on certain things and I'm
like as their adult I'm like I've been
there done that and I can
I gotta downtown is that thing it's like
it's important for me for a kid to
figure it out on their own but like I'm
like no it's not gonna be important in a
matter of two weeks I give you two weeks
tops
I think the last birthday ahead that I
was like super excited about was I think
I was trying 12
okyou yeah and it was like my mom gave
me like the Pokemon games that you that
was really popular before Pokemon games
yeah I mean the cards the gameboy games
are you gonna like catch pokemon that
the games a Pokemon game that was
popular before yeah my go yeah I had the
red blue and I was part of the craze of
that and then I think that was 12 years
old and then next year the pokemon gold
and silver came out like the next ones
and I was like
I don't care about this gold did you get
a career birthday
uh yeah our birthday oh you got the
golden silver for your birthday I think
it was like shared it's like my brother
you got a gold and I got dis Ober and so
then we could like trade you know if
he's like oh and I was doubtful with
that
speaking of Pokemon that is genius
marketing so like pokemon red had
certain types of pokemons and that
universe pokemon blue and certain types
of pokemons he could choose and in
capture right in order to capture them
all and you had to trade it was someone
that had a blue if you had red oh yeah
blue yeah
trade with someone's red that's genius
and my mom would then just get me one
and get my brother the other one Wow
we're gonna trade back and forth and
then we'd be you know self-contained
Pokemon masters so that's something you
cared about him that you stopped caring
your very quickly yeah they poked my
price happened and I was like yeah
getting to the age where I'm like too
old for it and then then I got too old
for it and I stopped carrying it then I
realized I don't think I get dopamine
hits from celebrations anymore oh so
this is not doing nothing for you know
that but it's coming back you know you
know it isn't it wasn't a SAR no that's
true because it's like I think you're a
kid you're you're easily excitable right
and you want to accelerate that yes yes
yes and it's like doping you yes and
excited and happy I want that I want
this for me and I think I got to a phase
in my life or it was just like anti
anything I just got to a place I like
I'm an anti-establishment and birthdays
are an establishment Wow
but then then and now I'm like I'm kind
of cool with it again I'm fine
you know is the funniest part though is
that you forgot how old you were
yes you're a true sign of you getting
old for sure but tell them how is it
that you're keeping track of your age I
can't keep track of my age by adding
either one year or two years on top of
test age depending on what my birthday
is so if it's my birthday I had two
years to test age and it's my and this
my age because I'm 30 32 tips 30 and
I'll always notice fur flavors are easy
I think she just matters more to me then
I mattered to myself for some reason not
like I'm your wife or anything yeah just
kidding when I read it to the bottom
that one I know for me it's Isaac I just
take his age and add 18 years oh that's
good for me too because I I just I need
to add 20 I had a nice round number here
I'm slaying guys again
[Music]
[Music]
this cake is crazy I put the entire tub
of frosting looks good let's try to like
move it out it came out kind of crazy oh
[Music]
man I'm nervous I have to write with
icing I've never done this before
what are you writing yeah Jenner break
with pink frosting does any have any
other like this is the frosting to the
left leap of faith you got it
wish i right no no way I haven't written
in cursive since I was like in
kindergarten push it right happy
birthday Casey that's too much
how about HPD and then and then see
happy v-day happy bday yeah okay now
with the h pd h pd and then my initials
CC and then you got HPD CC that blame
but it's it's it's like Larry five
letters I wanted to be cute Oh too thick
okay alright thank you
this is the people word are you doing a
pest you're patching it up
it looks like whiteout that's that's the
theme that theme if we learn anything
from the office and from Kelly from the
office its you get happy theme there's
always a theme that's the white out
theme this is my first kick I've ever
made
I'm really proud of you looks really
good like it looks really really good
[Music]
love it you got it
why is this so scary to do come sweaty
to the storm just flow with it oh man
maybe I should some cursive now I'm
thinking about it because maybe easier
to do cursive cuz you have to pick it up
wait but I can't do capitalize cursive
why did I choose capital letter you're
like I wish I could help you out here I
don't have any answers for you that's
why everyone does cursive on cakes
[Music]
it legible look it's super legible this
is gonna be the bestest cake ever
because of this person right here that
beauty my night
yeah boozy I mean that's all you could
have been shower after this I'm sweating
so much
[Music]
dan you're smooth with it now holy crap
who are you free hand the heart I like
it that hard does not it's a heart and
exclamation mark at the same time that
is skip that's my signature heart I like
to put a diet beat ever since I was in
high school I like doing that yeah
that's solid happy it was like I tried
and then birthday it's like hey she's
got it and then Casey she really yeah
yeah a lot of icing
you could write more stuff what you want
to write on science no it took all day
to do it
oh no fail
are you gonna do 32 for sure
for real you're local and then five
years that's a lot that's the most
candles I've ever had on a cake Oh like
it's great I love it
shall we light it yeah let's do it I put
my heart and love into this cake even
though I didn't make it from scratch but
I did make it from scratch because
there's no box will you talk about no
bucks yeah and then it was funny because
I turned off the burnt pieces of someone
good as new
yeah we should embalm it in some sort of
wax coating or something that preserve
it i oh yeah oh yeah this right here yes
these times that's what this whole
channel it's for so we were talking
we're like should on time them should we
go and get that dinner that we were
thinking about that I'd already told you
guys about earlier in the day that we're
planning on getting it but then I asked
you the birthday boy before it's a boy
you wanted to eat and you were like no I
just wanted to dig into this cake mm-hmm
and this could be your dinner so I make
for dinner hell yeah Oh tomorrow might
as well you don't know what I'm talking
about
was she talking about I don't know I
like it when you do your shoulder thing
that's the cutest thing in the world
happy birthday today oh by the way we
realize this is our first birthday
celebration maybe this house that we
built together yeah I know I just I
always forget that we solved this plug
Alaniz dirt yeah less than a year ago
true we put a deposit down for a piece
of land we got the build our house
that's pretty cool let's say well we
bought it from the developer they built
it for us we told them the colors of
that thing right yeah right Dallas
totally yes we picked that color
everything else they pretty much did
though there we go got it my boy you
have 32 candles to light I'm sorry for
being so old okay I have a lot of your
help people like oh no the wax is
melting I got to do this bastard it
makes it taste better though whoa this
one's really amazing happy birthday to
you happy birthday to you happy birthday
dear
daddy and like where we're going we see
happy birthday - hold it
I can't blow it one no you have to blow
them all out I'll give it and then you
make that I'm gonna make one wish so
important that it's worth 30 to a she's
come there we go or you could blow em
all and then in the future you can think
of 32 ish okay maybe nothin too true
oday they got so melted what I'm glad I
put them all on one side of the cake
[Music]